salut vous l'avez vu dans le titre
aujourd'hui on se fait un casse-tête
collector à 4400 44 euros ça vous
rappelle étrangement le prix de celui à
3333 euros de chèques à des puzzles
c'est normal c'est le nouveau casse-tête
collector de chêne cas des puzzles merci
à eux de me permettre de le faire ici
sur la chaîne
eh bien je vais aller le chercher donc
ça c'était pour vous rappeler l'ancien
maintenant je vais chercher le nouveau
on a reçu une grosse boîte veut bien
bonne grosse boîte que vous faudra j'ai
fait ça en arrivant et si on ouvre la
porte
y'a une clé est si jeune à claques les
j'ouvre la boîte et voici la feuq king
bestioles c'est incroyable alors ça
c'est ce qu'ils avaient fait pour
l'heure crowfunding donc ça ça va pas
servir ça non plus ça c'est les plans je
sais ça c'est la boussole et c'est donc
ce que je vais faire je prends de sa
m'ont dit que ça j'en ai peut-être
besoin pour accéder à des endroits
je vais prendre la lettre mais surtout
je prends la bête
je ne veux même pas le prendre il a
l'air incroyable mais il a l'air si
beaux arts oui comme ça on va pouvoir le
comparer quelques secondes et on n'est
pas sur le même niveau de détail la voie
où tu dis rien petite finale après après
tient bien ici vinci
loïc génériques
[Musique]
ok vous l'avez vu aujourd'hui j'ai le
hic est denis qui en dit wayne ou un
truc ce qu'il est pour toi tu mets ça
sur ta tete moi je les crois mes mecs
c'est des pros ok donc s'ils me disent
que je leur style est comme ça j'ai
averti le sgr style et moi je te crois
sur parole c'est la confiance
j'ai pris les lunettes parce que vu le
niveau de détail des trucs bien voir ce
sera pas c'est incroyable quand tu vois
les petits bonhommes dedans et tous ces
regards africains de regarder le niveau
de détail c'est incroyable ça c'est pour
allumer hu
[ __ ] mais il est trop trop beau que je
vais lire la lettre qu'ils ont envoyé
cette énigme a nécessité presque un an
de conception et un mois et demi de
montage
juste pour lui tout est fait à la main
nous espérons qu'elle vous plaira votre
mission si vous l'acceptez sera de
parcourir cette cité afin de percer ses
mystères dans cette configuration
actuelle cette boîte laisser site 116
mouvement pour est ouverte
comme d'habitude la force n'est pas
rockies comme vous avez constaté h et
hector est une mini cité peuplée de
petits êtres étranges aller rempli de
détails intéressants qu'ils ne vous
faudra pas rater afin de résoudre
l'énigme
nous faisons un bon moment christophe la
ronde et l'équipe de 24 des puzzles
merci beaucoup et le cas des puzzles
aller voir leur site en il ya des casse
tête comme ça un peu unique est un peu
cher mais il ya aussi des choses
beaucoup plus accessible respectueux de
l'environnement à chaque fois et est
dans une logique où pouvaient les
montées vous même et c'est donc là à
l'intérieur par exemple la joie un
escalier avec une porte qui est là
derrière et et surtout joie des symboles
et je suis sûr que ça ne servira plus
tard finale d'escalier il a l'air de
fonctionner dans les deux sens
je ne sais pas par quoi falloir
commencer on va trouver on peut le
mettre dans tous les sens au monde en
fait chaque phase l'impression qu'on
peut la voir différemment
ok on va se tourner les six faces une
par une et on va juste peut-être voir
une partie un peu exploration de caisse
qui peut bouger ou pas pour chercher le
le premier mouvement celui qui
celui qui va nous débloquer un peu alors
face du dessus on touche un peu à tout
comme ça légèrement sans forcer ici
c'est intéressant parce que ça ça
pourrait bouger et à quelque chose qui
bloque ici pour l'instant rien de
spécial là non plus là non plus là non
plus là non plus
donc là pourquoi lui peut pas se lever
ça c'est intéressant comme peut-être
qu'ils pourraient mais alors comment
qu'est-ce qu'il bloque il faut chercher
les éléments de bloquant là j'ai rien
qui bloque ici est-ce que ça apple fait
redescendre au hockey mais ça me bloque
toujours par contre je peux pas le
relever alors que j'ai le sentiment que
ça devrait pouvoir se relever ça donc là
j'ai juste plus descendre l'escalier et
peut-être je peux le descende encore
ouais encore à y a un truc derrière
est-ce que je peux le descendre encore
plus
est-ce que j'allume quelque chose là non
ça reste bien droit l'aed est descendu à
fond je le vois là buté qui alla donc à
la butte et là il est à fond est là
derrière jockey une petite ouverture
donc tu as sur cette phase on a pu
bouger ça on sait pas tellement pourquoi
mais on peut rentrer et sortir
l'escalier néanmoins c'est pas ça qui
m'intéresse le plus ce qui
m'intéresserait moi ce serait de lever
sa pourtant quand je fais ça je vois que
sa force là peut-être c'est juste
brainfuck net on peut pas du tout pour
le moment
cette phase là et cette race là on a un
peu explorées on va passer à cette phase
là elle nous dit pas grand chose non
plus haut le mur peut se bouger ah oui
d'accord elle le mur ok style et c'est
peut-être ne vous répondez pas là
cette bri l'aller amovible et le mur il
peut bouger
du coup en fonction de comment je la
déplace
il peut faire quelques moves ça ne fait
une sorte de lame bien envoyé
[Musique]
donc là on l'a dit on l'a on a bougé au
maximum de ce qu'on pouvait bouger ça
nous a libéré des petites choses ça nous
a surtout libéré une sorte de combat ou
en hockey là on a libéré un outil
littéralement là c'est un autre symbole
qu'on a ici au quai du coup ça aussi on
peut le bouger est ce que ça nous permet
de bouger autre chose ici je sais pas
encore est-ce que ça je peux ouvrir oui
je peux le l'ouvrir qu'est ce qu'il ya
derrière il ya une jeune femme qui dort
voyez on dirait son lit je peux le faire
monter puisque il ya une encoche
derrière donc là on a fait monter le lit
je sais pas trop à quoi ça nous a servi
mais à libérer la route peut-être oui
d'accord parce que tourner l'escalier
d'accord là on n'avait pas de chiffres
est là maintenant on a on a deux choses
contours là pour l'instant on avait rien
ici en bougeant ça on a libéré à un
moment donné ce symbole là et le chiffre
11 je pense pas que ce soit pour rien ok
cette phase elle était très intrigante
on a on a on a vu plein de choses sur
cette phase et on a trouvé ça qui est en
fait un compas qui va de 0 à 90 degrés
je suppose qui va nous servir tout à
l'heure à autre chose donc sur cette
façon à libérer ça et on a trouvé un
chiffre est un symbole on va continuer à
faire le tour des faces pour l'instant
on va avoir un petit peu ce que ça dit
ce côté là la petite maison aux halles
est bloqué mais donc limon si l on
pourra pas la bascule et à terme
ça ressemble un peu à un taquin je me
dis que si j'arrivais à enlever une
pièce peut-être que je pourrai tout
faire bouger et en plus ça donne
l'impression de pouvoir s'ouvrir
ok on va on va regarder maintenant un
petit peu je suis là j'avais aussi une
sorte de conte pas d'ailleurs il ya
encore il ya de nouveau des symboles il
ya de nouveau des chiffres
peut-être tort
17 15 j'ai vraiment l'impression que
c'est juste un outil de mesure mais que
pour l'instant rien n'est accessible
donc là aussi j'ai dénombré des chiques
j'essaie d'ici l'ag y ce coup ci tout ça
a l'air complètement thiéblot ah non pas
du tout d'accord ok ok tous à se tourner
ouais ok ok donc peut-être avec les
symboles liés au nombre qui a à côté
peut-être on va trouver quelque chose
comme là on peut voir le point
d'exclamation est liée à 16 là j'ai pas
le point d'exclamation ici mais si je
trouvais les autres symboles et le
chiffre qui donne correspond peut-être
je pourrais ouvrir ça ça est-ce que je
peux le manipuler pour le moment d'être
cette rue un nom et ça ressemblait un
peu l'ambiance
thales
[Musique]
récap j'essaye de vous expliquer ce que
je crois qu'on prend là on a les cinq
symboles différents ces cinq symboles je
les retrouve dans ces cinq sorte de
chapelle je me dis si avec ça je vise
une chapelle sam oriente admettons la
chapelle qui ressemble à une maison
celle ci ça m'oriente sur l'un des cinq
symboles qui est présenté ici
mais pour savoir lesquels mettre ici
puisque j'ai de la liberté de mouvement
complète de celui-là il faudrait que je
sache
vers quoi m'orienter tous les symboles
ne sont pas amis de la même manière
ensemble donc ça ça fait bouger un truc
de degré qui va de 0 à 90 de 0 à 90 ce
n'est pas sans nous rappeler que nous
avons de quoi mesurer cela si j'arrive à
savoir sur quel degré me m
grâce à ça qui va me permettre de
mesurer sûrement un écart à nantes
quelque chose je vais pouvoir ensuite le
reporter sur cette bécane là et après me
dire et du coup tel symbole c'est il
correspond à lui et lui comme ils sont
tous associés à des chiffres c'est le
chiffre que je dois mettre là-dedans je
pense qu'on est sur une bonne théorie
en gros ce que j'ai fait c'est tous les
symboles qu'on arrive à voir depuis tout
à l'heure un petit peu partout je les ai
reporter les dix huit chiffres et j'ai
mis les symboles que j'ai trouvée au fur
et à mesure là par exemple quand on
avait levé on avait vu qu'il y avait le
6 avec sage les mille ha bon jeu
l'éclaté sur les différentes faces quand
même pour pour mieux savoir où je les
trouvais la théorie est toujours là même
si j'arrive à reporter ici les symboles
que j'ai fait à une hyper que j'ai ici
ce que j'ai là alors la flèche bas
indique un des symboles mais
souvenez-vous g l'inclinaison 1 degré à
trouver mais je viens le comprends je
viens de comprendre que ces symboles ces
cinq symboles représentent les quatre
maisons qui a dessus donc je pense qu en
mesurant l'inclinaison du toit avec ça
je vais pouvoir trouver mon degré mais
il me manque une cinquième maison 5e
maison qui je pense est la maison qui
est caché la porte là je vais essayer de
noter les inclinaisons dans l'ordre
c'est d'abord la baraka un seul pan avec
un truc rond ici cl tissage le place
quand je peux je pollue placer le pour
mesurer ici peut-être je pense que c'est
là maintenant parce que là ça ne permet
pas bien mesuré où je trouve exactement
où placer ici ok si je le place ici là
je peux mesurer précisément il faut que
je le mesure je pense plutôt comme ça et
il fait 20 degrés donc la première barak
ça ça fait 20 degrés la deuxième barak
c'est celle qui fait à peu près cette
forme là avec un 3 nanas et un truc avec
cheminée qu'est-ce qu'il va manquer la
5e ainsi
voilà la théorie c'est sûr qu'elle est
bonne parce que tout s'emboîte
parfaitement donc ça c'est bon
l'inclinaison du toit et à 30 de sa c30
de dhr et ça ça fait du bien avancé on a
coupé mais ça fait une heure que je suis
dessus on a coupé pour préserver la
gauche ensuite ça c'est la maison qu'on
apporte ensuite il ya l'espèce de maison
qui est comme ça et ça c'est clairement
l attend mais je mesure quelle toile
assurent les deux c'est une question
pour moi je crois que je pense qu'il
faut mesurer ce twilight voilà il est
quoi il a cinquante mètres 55 degrés
avec un petit point d'interrogation est
donc la dernière ce qui à la tête un peu
d'une usine on va dire ça c'est celle ci
clairement où est ce que je mesure lui
non il faut que je mesure la bonne
inclinaison c'est lui oui c'est ça 80
degrés mais du coup celui que j'ai
marqué 55 c'est pas logique mon histoire
je pense qu'il faut prendre donc 65 en
réalité le premier c'est 20 degrés donc
si je me place à 20 degrés que je me
place sur lui
ça me donne le symbole des rouages que
je n'ai pas à lol
trittin je n'ai pas les rouages j'ai pas
cette cette forme là
bon alors le deuxième qui était à 30
degrés si je me place dessus ça me donne
à ça me donne celui ci ça c'était 15
si je me mets à 65 degrés donc c'est là
la petite maison c'est lui et lui sait
si sa c6 et 80 degrés c'est lui c'est le
panneau stop le panneau stop et disent
je vais quand même re mesurer lui là et
là en vrai je suis plus à 34 ans je sais
pas est-ce qu'il va falloir que je
cherche ce rouage que j'ai pas ou est ce
que tu as je sais pas il manque cette
saloperie de rouages la celui-là quand
même être quelque part est quelque part
où je leur ai pas trouvé pourtant j'ai
vraiment l'impression d'avoir tout
exploré ce que je pouvais bouger pour
lui
je ne comprendrai un truc regarder le
attendait là pour vous voyez bien en
fait la barre quand elle est en bas à
l'indic le zéro sauf que moi quand je
fais mes mesures
je mesurais
comme ça avec le petit pointage mais
c'est une connerie en fait il faut que
j'aligne le bois avec le bois donc mais
mesure déjà elles sont fausses du coup
c'est 65 pour lui du coup c'est plus
logique parce que quand j'avais un doute
sur un lui du coup faut que je sois bien
alignés dont cuisse et 20 degrés pour
lui ça doit être 10 degrés si bas bah
ouais et coûte 10 degrés 10,2 ray l aile
du coup ce serait 50 degrés on va au
moins reprendre ça j'ai dit que le
premier lui c'était 10 degrés du coup
rien à voir [ __ ] clé c'est trop bien
pensée a par contre donc lui ce serait
le stop et le stop seppi
[Musique]
revenons-en à nos moutons
moi je pense qu'il faut se concentrer
sur la libération de ça ça pour
l'instant
je n'arrive rien à y faire et ça j'avais
cet espoir là là sur ce truc où je pense
que ma théorie elles restent bonnes
parce que là ça j'ai dit que ça touchait
pas ça si j'arrive à avancer ça c'est
bon et ça ça marche pas et [ __ ] c'est
ça et ça ça bouge c'est comme le mur
j'aurais pu le trouver tout à l'heure
j'ai perdu énormément de temps pour rien
je regarde s'il ya pas des symboles en
même temps parce que du coup nous
montrent plein de symboles à je peux le
sortir car moi je peux pas le sortir pas
à oui mais par contre je peux tirer ça
voilà ce qui fait que là je peux tourner
ça maintenant notre symbole en dessous
coups d'accords bon c'est pas le symbole
que je cherchais c'est pas un de ceux
que je cherchais ça c'est le numéro 18
c'est l'espèce de vitrail comme ça et
surtout on a libéré la scrute amène en
eau
et oui c'est ça le truc où je vous
disais on peut pousser tout à l'heure on
peut pousser comme ça donc lui en faire
entrer hélas ce que je pressentais être
un jeu de taquin est un jeu de taquin ou
pas ok ça monte ça descend pas ça monte
donc si je le monte là je fais ça
oui je peux pas le descend au quai à la
gare de l'intérêt du coup je peux pas le
défendre
ça me sert pas tant ah ah ah oui j'ai ok
je vais faire une inversion commun comme
un ascenseur c'est un peu comme os x
cube et ça va me libérer celui de tout
temps ok tu vois l'idée inverse les
gauches droites comme ça là parce que ça
me permet de faire quelque chose de
spécial
ces lycées forcément lié à l'escalier
non pour moi c'est lié forcément à lui
est ce que j'ai un truc me ce qu'est ce
que si j'appuie 6 avait quelque chose
or oui trop bien assez stylé on ya le
truc de l'architecte là à [ __ ] il
était cochée ans ou trop bien donc le 13
c'est le truc de l'architecte donc le 13
ce serait donc lui ce serait aux lui ce
serait très vite un j'écris comme un
porc lui sept cas il manque créé le
grand h mais attends c'est surtout
est-ce qu'en faisant ça maintenant je
peux me libérer lui j'imagine que au
[ __ ] il m'a sur le côté je l'avais pas
vu le cube est dans un bon je cherchais
pas mais on l'a il n'empêche que ça
maintenant je dois bien pouvoir en faire
quelque chose là sur le côté avec tout
ce que j'aime libérer la ici c'est bien
ça qui devrait me libérer de sa à ben
voilà on peut le pousser là on peut le
tirer au mais un petit truc derrière il
ya le hash qui fait plaisir
donc le hc le 3
donc lui ce sera le 3 donc là il nous
manquerait plus en admettant que les
codes soit bonne et avec mes report il
soit bon il nous manquerait plus que la
maison que j'ai pas pu relever qui est
de l'autre côté parfois c'est un peu
plus à leur poursuite du coup si toi je
te tournes tu me libère encore un
symbole c'est le neuf et ça ressemble à
l'autre mais pas tout à fait parce que
c'est plus vers le haut
en fait et ça et ça maintenant ça vient
c'était sûr c'était tellement sur ok
puisque ça c'est venu ça on va le mettre
là et là j'espère que ça va me faire
monter la maison un truc comme ça
est-ce que ça à d'accord ok ah ok
d'accord
là c'était look et la cds look et je
peux pousser là comme je peux pousser là
du coup je peux monter la maison là et
après ça on s'en fiche
ok et du coup cette maison maintenant je
vais pouvoir la mesurer
un [ __ ] je peux bouger ça aussi styles
et genres et tous tripoter mais ne
tripote pas tout tout de suite famille
l'inclinaison de cette maison était le
bois était collé jusqu'à temps qu'on
soit comme ça donc est ce que j'ai un
endroit là pour le faire donc le truc un
peu space
ce serait 35 degrés si ces 35 degrés que
je le place là ça me fait de trucs avec
le point d'exclamation on l'avait eue
c'est le cède donc le chou
ce serait celle entre temps j'ai vu que
ça je pouvais bouger un peu ça mais je
vais y aller après je vais d'abord allé
voir
du coup les petites maisons elles se
seraient 13 pour la maison simple celui
qu'on sait pas ce que c'est ce serait du
coup j'ai 10 16
le point d'exclamation
3 l'espèce du leasing pour moi je
l'appelle lusine ce serait cette hockey
est-ce que de ça je peux faire quelque
chose sûre c'est rien du tout mais je
les ai mises selon moi dans l'ordre
qu'il ouvre les proust roms qui ne se
passe strictement rien céder très
décevant ça alors je vais retourner à
mes maisons donc le rouage ce serait 12
l'espèce de rouages
je croyais avoir besoin tout à l'heure
là il ya un plan de maison l'instant va
bien tout bouger pour avoir tout ce qui
nous est libéré l'ag le triangle sa c4
d'accord bon je passe mon bac
il n'y a rien ici à rien ah j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut que je reproduis
ça si ça se trouve
non parce qu'il n'ya pas des gravures
sur qui
[Musique]
donc en fait en reproduisant la
construction de la maison comme comme
c'était sur le dessin là maintenant
j'arrive à tout enfoncé on voit les pico
dedans mais je n'arrive pas à savoir
pourquoi est ce que quand gens font ce
jeu pourrait coulisser par là parce que
comme ça me met toutes au même socle
non y'a vraiment zéro jeu ça pour moi
c'est censé être un peu la fin tu vois
mais il se passe rien de spécial sur la
boîte quoi ça s'enfonce pas se coller
complètement ici à 20 8 me et les
rebords là qu'il bloque après ton ce nom
j'appuie au max jeu refaire les mesures
et les codes andreu doigt que ça à faire
on va partir sur la feuille blanche on
va vérifier la maison pencher elle se
mesure dans ce sens là et elle nous
donne exactement 10 degrés ça nous donne
mais sur le dise ici déjà et ensuite va
sur la maison chez nous et ça nous donne
le stop
en plus c'était ça ensuite ça c'est la
maison quand même plus l'air d'être sa
20° 20 degrés
reporter ici ça nous donne sur cette
maison-là le le compas des francs maçons
à quelle étape je l' ai vu le compas des
maçons à c'était sous c'était là dessous
voilà c'est ça donc c'est 13 13
[Musique]
ok maintenant je reporte tout sur les
disques ici lui il part en 3 et lui y
par an 7 et d'un coup ça peut bouger
c'est intéressant je sais pas pourquoi
mais j'ai pu la maison que j'avais si
brillamment construit tout à l'heure
qu'est-ce que j'ai foutu depuis ok ça
c'était dans ce sens là ouais ok ça
qu'est ce que ça fait maintenant ça fait
toujours rien donc ça c'est parfait
c'est exactement ce qu'on voulait que ça
ne fasse rien un peu le leitmotiv de
cette une vidéo la samah décalé ça ici
est-ce que du coup je te bouger ça parle
à 20 ans oui oui bon j'ai pu pour quoi
faire
jeanne est foutrement aucune idée j'ai
pu décaler sa d'un cran hélas si je
réalise a fait quelque chose ou pas au
chalet tu viens de me dire quoi tu vas
me dire tu as là pour quand même temps
tu me demande quand tu trouves que les
tournages ils sont trop longs l'eau et
que tu m'en parles tu viens me voir et
hume on parle quoi ouah ouah il était
incroyable ncaa des puzzles christophe
la honte france architecte au ces le
numéro 2 sur 44 donc y en a bien que 44
et ça c'est le numéro 2 incroyable je
peux virer sept veaux pro kim explose le
front loïc ce puzzle était fou alors
pose incluse
on a mis il est 17 heures on a commencé
à 14h30 on a mis deux heures et demie il
était incroyable mais vraiment c'était
un truc de ouf
bravo à une cas des puzzles mais bravo
merci à eux de construire des choses
aussi folle et donc si vous allez sur
leur système cadets ils vendent soit des
choses qui font eux mêmes comme ça donc
là vous avez vu un mois et demi pour le
monter que tu vois des kits d'assemblage
et vous construisez le vôtre aussi bien
pour mécanisme à que j'avais fait dans
la vidéo précédente ou pour architecte
aulas celui ci allait aller faire un
tour sur leur site c'est très très cool
ce qu'ils font tant il était fou il m'a
rendu ou ceux qui ont dit dans la vidéo
précédente rue porte
1333 rosam prêcher de le finir aussi
vite je vous rappelle que la difficulté
n'est pas lié aux prix le prix n'est pas
un symbole des difficultés mais là
vraiment celui ci il ya de quoi se
prendre la tête c'est à dire que si en
plus n'a pas l'habitude de faire des
casse tête tu galères c'est sûr par
contre à une pièce de collection elle
est folle
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
je ne sais pas sur faire toujours des
casse tête de plus en plus cher parce
que la boîte va couper clairement un
moment donné mais on va essayer de
continuer trouver des choses comme ça
très original merci à vous d'avoir
regardé partialité cette vidéo là ça
fait extrêmement plaisir
abonnez-vous c'est gratuit activer la
cloche pour pas rater les prochaines
vidéos des joies de l'algorithme sont ce
qu'elles sont je compte sur vous pour le
faire pour me récompenser de sa
peut-être peut-elle mérite ça non oui
dites moi des casse tête que voulait que
je résolvant commentaire même votre
thème de maths
pourquoi pas moi je suis à l'écouté ici
je vous mets l'ancien casse tête que
j'avais fait deux chaînes cas des
puzzles ici un autre casse-tête 15000
euros
et puis prenez soin de vous et à très
bientôt cha cha cha cha haut